buenas noches con todos es un placer
estar aquí en mi casa la uni y les
quiero contar acerca de algo
en el mundo que conocí de niña lo más
cercano a un parque era este pompón y a
pesar de que eran espacios muy grandes
de día nadie lo estaba ocupando
pero de noche lo único seguro era que
habían delincuentes o pandilleros que se
peleaban entre sí y nadie hacía
absolutamente nada todos estaban en
nuestras casas asustados porque soñamos
que algún día podríamos vivir en otros
lugares pensábamos que nuestro paso por
nuestro barrio era de pronto que podía
cambiarse y podíamos irnos a otro lugar
no había una apropiación del lugar donde
estábamos y yo siempre me preguntaba si
solo me pasaba a mí y no con el tiempo
que no sólo era yo no sería mi barrio no
sólo era mi distrito ni mi cuadra eran
distritos de lima eran ciudades del perú
y esta ciudad es de toda latinoamérica
sólo tenemos tres de los nueve metros
cuadrados que la o ms la organización
mundial de la salud recomienda para
tener ciudades saludables
y lo más preocupante es que el 80% de
estos espacios que existen están en
estado de abandono esto más o menos son
56 millones de áreas de graves en estado
de desuso abandonados que más o menos si
lo comparamos con algo que conocemos son
cinco mil canchas de fútbol y si nos
ponemos a pensar lima encima de todo
está sentado sobre un desierto clima es
la segunda ciudad asentada sobre un
desierto después de el cairo y la
situación es aún más preocupante porque
el recurso del agua es muchísimo más
escasa en otras ciudades
pero por qué pasa esto primero porque
todos los parques que está la ciudad de
lima los parques que se diseñan se
generan sin que a nadie nos consulte
cómo quieres tu parque se hacen con
diseños que están preestablecidos y no
sólo eso sino que las especies que se
plantan en esos espacios no son
apropiadas para nuestro clima ni para
soportar las sequías
y aparte de todo esto el uso de la
cisterna como riego es realmente un
desperdicio de agua y no sólo eso sino
que mata las las pequeñas plantas que
pueden estar creciendo por eso que
muchos de los municipios no toman en
cuenta o no creen prioritario tener
áreas verdes
ahora imagínense que para la creación de
un parque a las personas se les consulte
cómo es que sea su parque
pero además se planta en especies
nativas de la zona es decir nativa del
desierto que puedan soportar las sequías
y además que estas plantaciones que sean
hermosas que generen la área verde que
puedan generar un riego sostenible y que
puedan tener un parque hermoso y verde
todo el año se plantan especies
comercializables es decir que con su
venta se puedan generar recursos para
poder revertirlo en la sostenibilidad
del parque es decir especies que pueden
ser vendidas y con lo que se genera se
puede generar el riego tecnificado se
puede hacer el tema de la población se
pueda generar muchísimos recursos ahora
imagínense que ese parque con estos
recursos pueden generar cíclicamente que
nadie los tram que sostener que por sí
mismos se puedan sostener solos esto es
un parque productivo ahora imagínense
que este parque productivo pueda generar
otros parques productivos en el tiempo
que puede ayudar a la creación con sus
recursos a que más áreas verdes se cree
pero que se conecten en
o más
y las comunidades replicando lo
aprendido en uno para que puedan llevar
a los demás
para poder hacer esto nosotros teníamos
que buscar un espacio verde un espacio
verde pero que estaba en estado de
abandono y bueno nosotros encontramos
hicimos un mapeo y la lista era
interminable pero teníamos que tener dos
características el primer lugar que
estos espacios debían llegar a la mayor
cantidad de personas es decir a la mayor
cantidad de vecinos que estaban
alrededor y eran parte de la comunidad y
en segundo lugar necesita que la
población esté organizada por eso
llegamos al salvador y el salvador ha
sido un distrito que ha sido invadido de
manera planificada es decir se llegó con
los planos y espacios para él para los
parques existían pero se necesitaban
espacios para otras cosas
entonces las prioridades empezaron a
ampliarse
villa el salvador además de una fuerte
conexión con la población las juntas
comunales trabajan de manera en conjunto
y son los mismos pobladores que han
hecho en algunos casos sus pistas o sus
veredas entonces por eso llegamos a vía
el salvador y el lugar que escogimos aún
es lugar muy especial porque fue el
lugar donde mi socio feliz creció de
niño y nuestra primera década fue
una persona valiente que nos ayudó con
toda la comunidad así que llamé a mis
amigos a danielle y así empezamos esta
aventura
lo primero que hicimos fue convocar a
toda la comunidad y les mencionamos que
queríamos hacer su par que muchos de los
vecinos de pronto no decían ustedes son
políticos o que cosas lo que quieren de
nosotros y nos dimos cuenta que el
primer paso para generar un parque no
era plantar un árbol o no era de repente
generar bancas el primer paso para hacer
un parque era tener la confianza de la
comunidad tener la confianza de la gente
y eso no lo íbamos a lograr con mucho
trabajo arduo y con mucha perseverancia
así que empezamos los talleres de sueños
y que eran los talleres de sueños era
generar que los mismos vecinos puedan
soñar su parque puedan soñar qué es lo
que quieren dentro soñar como quieran
sus bancas como quieren sus pistas como
quieren sus veredas como que sus
mobiliarios y también más veámoslo
de vulnerabilidad es el taller de
película para conocer cuáles son los
peligros
por ejemplo dónde es que se como la el
desmonte donde se acumula la basura no
está la mayor cantidad de gente que
empieza a hacer cosas terribles dentro
del estos espacios y junto con toda esta
información
creamos un diseño
en el 80% de los espacios lo generamos
junto con los vecinos con árboles
nativos con zonas para jugar un árbol
como un parque normal
y en el 20% lo volvemos un productivo a
una especie pueda ser comercial
y una de las primeras especies que hemos
utilizado es el bambú
y ustedes se preguntarán por qué el
bambú bueno para empezar el bambú no es
un árbol como muchos pueden pensar no el
bambú pertenece a la familia de las
gramíneas es decir es la familia de los
pastos es el pasto más alto del mundo y
el bambú genera infinidad de propiedades
la primera es que se regenera
rápidamente es para los cuatro años uno
puede tener plantaciones hasta adecuar
de 20 a 30 metros de alto
puede llegar a reforestar todo un bosque
de un solo porque se regenera a través
de los rizomas es decir el bambú a
diferencia de un árbol no crece hacia
arriba sino crece hacia abajo
de sus raíces caminando y saliendo otro
bambú bebé y el bambú bebé cada vez es
más gordito que el bambú padre entonces
en un bosque por ejemplo ni si nosotros
observamos un bosque de bambú los bambús
más gorditos son los más tiernos
pero no solo además de poder mejorar la
biomasa del parque es decir
tener a los útiles el bambú lo que hace
es que se puede utilizar para infinidad
de productos desde telas desde comida
cuadernos o viviendas porque la especie
que utilizamos el agua de whist y folk
ya el bambú latino
oriundo de latinoamérica así que
comenzamos con que los vecinos pudieran
adoptar un bambú y pudiera encariñarse
con ellos le pusieron un nombre los
cuidaron empezaron a compartir entre sus
experiencias y género es que vecinos que
hacía 30 años vivían en el mismo lugar
era la primera vez que conversaban la
primera vez que se saludaban que
conversaban juntos y de pronto que se
hacían amigos
empezamos con la jornada de limpieza
pero aquí nos dimos que además del
desmonte que había dentro de los parques
hacía diez años en este espacio
y muchos de vías elevador y de repente
en otros distritos la municipalidad
había enterrado muchos camiones de
desmonte dentro del parque es decir lo
que nos tenía que tomar casi un mes nos
tomó cuatro o cinco meses
pero aparte de por nada de limpieza
mientras todos estamos trabajando nos
llegó la lluvia así que trabajamos con
bolsas o con cosas sin cables para poder
seguir trabajando pero también nos
pasaron cosas muy bonitas de pronto una
señora que nos ni no sabía otros pasos
hoy nos vio y nos quiso invitar
carapulcra una olla gigante de
carapulcra para todos los que estaban
presentes y no sólo eso debajo de todo
este desmonte habían sobrevivido plantas
nativas de la zona habían árboles de
higo habían manzanas habían piñas así
que habían sobrevivido a la sequía a
normar los han sobrevivido a todos estos
años de no haberlos cuidado
nosotros trabajamos un parque productivo
bajo muchas áreas para los vecinos ellos
se dedican fit por ejemplo anfiteatro
zonas para jugar son más para los niños
existían ya huertos urbanos que ellos
mismo habían plantado muchísimos años
antes así que se observó absolutamente
todas las áreas verdes que ya existían
pero se enmarcó todo bajo tres líneas de
diseño espacios para el arte espacios
para el deporte y para la aventura tenía
anfiteatros teníamos bicitekas zonas
para juegos una es para tripas
y lo primero que se generó fue los
árboles nativos árboles como el moho y
el palo verde y el jacarandá que son
solamente para zonas áridas como en las
que vivimos y no sólo eso si no todos
los vecinos serán parte de esto y se
empoderaron para seguir trabajando
juntos
así que empezó a trabajarse en modo
comunal y que era un nado comunal bueno
era un grupo de vecinos elegidos por
todos eran los encargados de transformar
este bambú que habíamos plantado en el
20 parques y lo podían comercializar
ellos serán los encargados de poder
comercializarlo venderlo a una empresa
cualquiera o poder utilizarlos ellos
mismos con ese dinero poder crecer y
generando su parque y así generar este
ciclo el ciclo de sostenibilidad del
parque para esto nuestros dos
principales han sido los voluntarios han
sido la comunidad misma ha sido la
municipalidad y empresas
aliaga como excel on air con el cual
trabajamos su compost
pero cuál es la importancia del parque
muchos pensarán que un parque es un
bonito donde hay mariposas y pajaritos
pues no un parque es la casa o en las
viviendas la familia se reúne en enlazar
el comedor para poder conversar pasar
mismo en un parque en la sala o comedor
que pasa acción una familia los hijos
simplemente van todos a sus cuartos
trabajan en sus computadoras y no se ven
todo el día lo que pasa es que empiezan
a hacer familias que no empiezan a
conversar entre ellos cada uno resuelve
su problema a su modo nadie conversa
todos estos súper desalineados y lo que
genera que si hay algún tipo de problema
a nadie se entera y de pronto si hay
algún tipo de conflicto puede estallar
de manera estrepitosa lo mismo pasa en
los espacios públicos en los parques
por ello en los parques se respeta a las
personas se genera la civilidad se
generan nuevos lazos el roce social hace
que uno pueda poner límites empiecen a
resolverse conflictos sociales que es
tan importante para tener barrio san
félix actualmente yo parque que nos
implica 500 familias es decir 2500
personas ya que trabajamos en espacios
de 1000 metros cuadrados
son los beneficios de tener un parque
productivo porque yo tendría un parque
productivo por mi casa en primer lugar
todos los parques que están trabajándose
como espacios verdes mejoran la calidad
de vida de las personas pero no sólo eso
sino que las viviendas que están
alrededor de estos parques aumentan su
valor comercial en un 20 por ciento más
se mejora la seguridad de la zona porque
para tener a 10 más seguras no es
necesario que pongamos cámaras o
guachimanes para tener ciudades más
seguras es necesario tener actividades
es necesario tener personas abuelitos
que están sacando a sus nietos personas
que están caminando porque empiezan a
hacer los ojos y dos naturales de
nuestro parque y si pasa algo ellos son
los que empiezan a salir porque de
pronto las personas que quieren hacer
algo malo se van a otro lugar porque ya
no les gusta esto no les gusta que hay
mariposas personas que esté jugando
pero no sólo eso un parque productivo
genera y con negocios a través de la
transformación del bambú nosotros
trabajamos a través de talleres
participativos y talleres de fabricación
para poder transformar el bambú
campesinos se genera además un pulmón
verde y se ahorra el material que ya se
tiene dentro del espacio y solo es que
en aceptar que andar que es una empresa
social peruana que lo que hace es que
parques productivos y cómo lo hace a
través de la fabricación cosecha y
generación de productos a base de bambú
como lo hacemos en realidad porque no
queríamos quedarnos en un solo sueño
primero nosotros generamos con nuestras
ventas de productos la financiamiento
para poder sostener estos parques
transformamos el bambú que generan los
nuevos comunales y a través de un
proceso de laminado
lo convertimos desde la caña hasta una
tabla
de repente todos han visto que las casas
rústicas utilizan el bambú simplemente
como caña nosotros lo que hacemos es un
proceso de laminado cortamos cada una de
las tiritas de este bambú y lo
transformamos a través de un prensado y
un pegado es una especie de tabla
generando esta tabla uno ya puede
generar cualquier tipo de producto que
haría con una madera y lo combinamos con
la fabricación digital
y nuestro primer producto ha sido los
lentes de sol y muchos se preguntarán
pero porque lentes de sol
teníamos muchísimos otros diseños de
muebles o algún tipo de artículo de
repente de la casa pero nosotros
necesitábamos un producto que uno lo
puede llevar en su día a día y que
además sea un referente para mostrarlo
en tu trabajo para mostrarlo con tus
amigos
con un self y ayudaba muchísimo a
transmitir el mensaje a diferencia de un
mueble que de repente lo tienes en tu
casa y sólo lo ve la familia o las
personas que te visitan y se acuerdan
que las áreas verdes las trabajábamos
bajo tres líneas de diseño bueno los
parques los trabajamos justamente bajo
esas tres líneas de diseño la línea
artista la línea deportista y la línea
venture' era
pero como hemos esto posible les cuento
que yo he vivido entre maderas entre
lijadoras entre trabajadores que
transformaban porque tengo una herencia
de mi papá que ha trabajado de madera
por muchísimo tiempo casi 40 años y por
eso pudimos transformar que la industria
de la madre pueda transformar a
generalizar y poder transformar la
industria del bambú
además que gracias a mi socio que
trabaja para la fabricación digital
pudimos combinar ambas cosas la
fabricación tradicional con la
fabricación y tal
y como hacíamos escalable esto porque
obviamente es una idea bonita y todo
pero cómo es que podíamos llegar a
vender más porque nosotros realmente lo
que queríamos hacer es su mayor para
crear parques activos poder generar el
todo lo que podamos ayudar de manera muy
directa que se pueda llegar a más
personas que se puedan ver más talleres
que se puedan comprar más plantas que se
puedan implementar más cosas obviamente
necesitamos financiamiento y para ello
teníamos que tener alguna forma de poder
escalar en la venta de los productos una
de las que hicimos
es generar puntos de venta en todo lima
tenemos puntos de venta en lima y en
arequipa y luego empezamos a trabajar ya
exportando a europa para poder generar
una mayor alcance y otro primer punto de
venta propio recién lo vamos a inaugurar
este 28 de noviembre en el jockey plaza
así que es un punto para poder generar
muchísimo más impacto porque
necesitábamos poder crecer más y para
poder crecer más teníamos que vender más
porque nosotros somos una empresa social
somos un híbrido entre uno una ong y una
empresa normal
cuál es nuestro sueño poder en 5 años
podamos tener diez parques productivos
que estén conectados entre sí y que se
pueda transmitir toda la información y
se pueda compartir lo que hacen dentro
de estos parques sobre todo todos los
cimientos que se transmiten y poder
pasarlo de parque en parking
y sobre todo pasar de los dos metros
cuadrados de área verde que tenemos a
los nueve que es lo mínimo que
necesitamos para tener ciudades
saludables
no les había contado pero antarki es una
palabra aymara es una leyenda de un niño
que sueña con volar y que le pide todas
las fuerzas la naturaleza para poder
lograrlo en sí todos tenemos un niño
dentro que sueña os tenemos parking
porque al final no se trata de un parque
no se trata de un lente no se trata del
bambú se trata en realidad de las
personas del amor que hay entre ellas de
ser solidarios de luchar por nuestros
niños y poder transmitir la información
y compartir todo lo que sabemos se trata
de ver el mundo de otra forma
se trata de ser felices gracias
[Aplausos]